♪ ♪
>> Kimberly: MICHAEL COHEN
APPEARED IN FEDERAL COURT TODAY
TO PROTECT THE FILE SEIZED BY
THE FBI.
HE DIDN'T WON.
A JUDGE REJECTED HIS AND
MR. TRUMP'S REQUEST FOR
TEMPORARY RESTRAINING ORDER THAT
WOULD'VE KEPT THEM FROM
PROSECUTORS.
ADULT FILM STAR STORMY DANIELS
SHOWED UP AND SHE ALLEGES SHE
WAS PAID BY COHEN TO KEEP AN
AFFAIR WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
QUIET.
HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID WHEN SHE
LEFT THE COURTHOUSE.
>> FOR YEARS, MR. COHEN HAS
ACTED LIKE HE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
HE HAS CONSIDERED HIMSELF AND
OPENLY REFERRED TO HIMSELF AS
MR. TRUMP'S FIXER.
HE HAS PLAYED BY A DIFFERENT SET
OF RULES, OR SHOULD WE SAY NO
RULES AT ALL.
HE HAS NEVER THOUGHT THAT THE
LITTLE MAN OR ESPECIALLY WOMEN,
EVEN MORE WOMEN LIKE ME, MATTER.
THAT ENDS NOW.
MY ATTORNEY AND I ARE COMMITTED
TO MAKING SURE THAT EVERYONE
FINDS OUT THE TRUTH AND THE
FACTS OF WHAT HAPPENED.
I GIVE MY WORD THAT WE WILL NOT
REST UNTIL THAT HAPPENS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Kimberly: THAT WAS STORMY
DANIELS MAKING A STATEMENT
OUTSIDE THE COURTHOUSE AFTER THE
JUDGE MADE THE RULING TODAY,
JUDGE WOOD REGARDING THE
DISCLOSURE OF THE DOCUMENTS.
NEWS TODAY OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT MICHAEL
COHEN WAS TRYING TO KEEP PRIVATE
AND GET A RESTRAINING ORDER
ISSUED TO PREVENT THE RELEASE OF
THOSE MATERIALS COMING OUT.
>> Dana: RIGHT, SO THERE WAS A
LOT OF THINGS HAPPENING IN COURT
TODAY.
IT'S HIGHLY UNUSUAL.
THIS IS A HIGHLY UNUSUAL
SITUATION TO HAVE SOMEBODY WHO
IS THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYER, TO
HAVE THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF
NEW YORK, THE FBI DO THE RAID TO
COME AND GET THE INFORMATION.
THEN QUESTIONS OF
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
THAT WAS IN COURT TODAY.
ONE OF THE THINGS THE JUDGE
REQUIRED WAS THAT MICHAEL: HAD
TO SAY WHO ARE YOUR CLIENTS.
GIVE ME THE LIST OF CLIENTS.
HE SAID THE FIRST ONE IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE THIRD ONE I'M GOING TO KEEP
ANONYMOUS.
AT THE REQUEST OF EVERYBODY.
I WANT TO KEEP IT QUIET.
BY THE END OF THE HOUR, IT'D
BEEN REVEALED IT WAS
SEAN HANNITY.
HE SAID ACTUALLY HE'S NEVER DONE
ANYTHING ON MY BEHALF LEGALLY
BUT I HAVE TALKED TO HIM FROM
TIME TO TIME ON LEGAL THINGS,
LIKE REAL ESTATE ET CETERA.
ALL OF THIS IS SWIRLING AROUND
AT THE TIME WHEN THE JUDGE IS
SAYING WE NEED TO HAVE THIS
INFORMATION BECAUSE WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU WANT US TO
KEEP PRIVILEGE.
SO THAT WHEN THE TEAMS ARE
LOOKING AT THIS, THEY KNOW WHAT
IS ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE AND
WHAT'S NOT.
>> Kimberly: GREG.
SEAN HANNITY ISSUING A STATEMENT
SAYING HE NEVER ACTUALLY
RETAINED OR TRANSACTED WITH
MICHAEL: IN TERMS OF PAYING HIM
BUT THAT HE WOULD CONSULT THEM
FROM TIME TO TIME ON CERTAIN
MATTERS AND THAT HE HAS EIGHT
ATTORNEYS.
HE USES THAT FOR A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT --
>> Greg: FULL DISCLOSURE.
I AM A SECRET CLIENT OF JACOBY
AND MYERS.
I HAD AN ACCIDENT WITH A
PICCOLO.
THEY GOT ME A SIX-FIGURE
SETTLEMENT.
SO THANK YOU.
LEAVE IT TO SEAN TO BE PART OF A
SCANDAL AND HAVE THE LEAST
SALACIOUS PARTED.
HIS STUFF IS SO COMMON SENSE.
I LOVE THIS.
I LOVED IT SO MUCH FOR YOU GO ON
TWITTER.
EVERYBODY WAS CONVULSING WITH
JOY OVER THIS NEWS.
THEY THOUGHT WE HAVE ANOTHER
SCALP.
IT'S GOING TO BE AMAZING.
THESE LITTLE BLUE CHECKS,
COMRADES TOGETHER HOPING, SEEING
THIS IS GOING TO BE THE BEST DAY
EVER.
OF COURSE, IT NEVER ENDS UP
BEING WHAT THEY WANT.
IT NEVER IS.
IT DEFLATES.
ALL OF THAT ENERGY SPENT ON
HOPING THAT SOMEBODY YOU DON'T
LIKE IS DESTROYED SHOWS HOW
PETTY YOU ARE.
>> Kimberly: JESSE, YOUR
THOUGHTS, AND ALSO
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS TWEETING ON
THIS, SAYING HOW ATTORNEY-CLIENT
PRIVILEGE IS NOW DEAD IN THIS
COUNTRY BECAUSE OF THIS INVASION
IN TERMS OF PRIVACY AND
PRIVILEGE AND OBTAINING
DOCUMENTS.
>> Jesse: IT'S A DIFFICULT
CASE TO ASSESS BECAUSE YOU DON'T
REALLY KNOW WHAT THESE
PROSECUTORS ARE AFTER.
DO THEY HAVE SOMETHING ON A
SETTLEMENT?
DO THEY HAVE A THING ABOUT
RUSSIA?
SOMETHING TOTALLY UNCONNECTED?
I'M HAVING A HARD TIME
DISSECTING IT.
THAT SAID, LOOKING BACK FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE, IT'S VERY TROUBLING
WHEN YOU HAVE THESE PEOPLE
RAIDING THE LAW OFFICES AND HOME
OF THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYER.
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE, IT'S
A SACRED PRIVILEGE.
LOOKS LIKE IT'S AT RISK.
AT THE SAME TIME, IT SEEMS VERY
AGGRESSIVE AND DRAMATIC FOR THEM
TO DO THAT.
IF I REALLY TRUMP TEAM LAWYERS,
I WOULD SAY LISTEN, THIS IS
POISON IN THE WELL.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO COOPERATE.
I WOULD BE PRETTY MAD AT
ROSENSTEIN TO SIGN OFF ON IT.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IT LOOKS LIKE
THERE'S A DOUBLE STANDARD WITH
THE WAY HILLARY'S LAWYER WAS
TREATED AND THE WAY TRUMP'S
LAWYER WAS TREATED.
OBVIOUSLY DIFFERENT CASES BUT IT
AFTER THE PERCEPTION THAT HE'S
BEING TREATED DIFFERENTLY.
THE CLEAN TEAM GOING THROUGH THE
FILES.
AT THIS POINT IT AT THIS
JUNCTURE, THERE IS NO ONE CLEAN.
I DON'T TRUST ANYBODY.
I DON'T THINK THE PRESIDENT
TRUST THESE PEOPLE.
I DON'T THINK HILLARY'S TEAM
TRUSTED THESE PEOPLE.
LAWYERS ARE GREAT WHEN YOU ARE
IN TROUBLE.
WE ARE A NATION OF LAWS.
THEY CAN PROTECT YOU AND YOU
NEED TO BE PROTECTED.
LAWYERS, ONE THEY WANT TO GET
YOU, THEY CAN GET YOU.
I WOULD BE VERY UPSET, VERY
SCARED IF I HAVE THESE PEOPLE
KNOCKING AT MY DOOR AND RAIDING
MY OFFICES.
SOMETIMES INNOCENT PEOPLE ARE
CONVICTED.
SOMETIMES GUILTY PEOPLE GET OFF
SCOT-FREE.
I WOULD HATE TO BE IN THE MIDDLE
OF ANY OF THIS.
>> Greg: WHAT ARE THEY GOING
TO FIGHT IN YOUR OFFICE, JESSE?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: I DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICE.
>> Kimberly: WATTERS' WORLD
T-SHIRTS.
LOTS OF THEM.
>> Greg: LOTS OF SWAG.
>> Juan: IN RESPONSE TO WHAT
JESSE WAS SAYING, IT WAS A LEGAL
WARRANT.
>> Jesse: AND LOT OF LEGAL
THINGS IN THIS COUNTRY THAT CAN
TURN PEOPLE'S LIVES UPSIDE DOWN.
YOU LOOK AT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
WITH CLINTON AND BUSH AND NOW
THIS.
WAS THE OUTCOME THE WAY WE
WANTED OR EXPECTED?
NO, THEY RUN PEOPLE'S LIVES
THROUGH THE RINGER.
A LOT OF TIMES UNFAIRLY.
WHEN THIS WHOLE THING OPEN UP,
WE SET OURSELVES WHEN THEY
APPOINT THESE PEOPLE, YOU NEVER
KNOW WHICH WAY IT CAN GO.
THIS TURNED SIDEWAYS.
AGAIN, THIS COUNTRY'S BEEN
TURNED UPSIDE DOWN AND EVERYONE
IS LAUGHING AT US.
>> Juan: WAIT A SECOND.
THE COUNTRY HAS BEEN TURNED
UPSIDE DOWN BY THE FBI AND DOJ?
>> Jesse: JUAN, YOU DON'T KNOW
WHERE THIS CAN GO.
QUESTIONABLE FROM THE BEGINNING.
>> Juan: I DON'T AGREE WITH
THAT BUT I DO THINK PART OF THE
MANDATE GIVEN TO MUELLER AS THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL WAS THAT IF YOU
DISCOVER ANYTHING BEYOND
POSSIBLE COLLUSION, IT'S PART OF
YOUR JOB.
>> Jesse: A VERY BROAD
MANDATE.
THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T LIKE THE
APPOINTMENT TO BEGIN WITH.
>> Juan: LET ME SAY TO ME,
IT'S A LEGAL WARRANT.
INVOLVING SEVERAL REPUBLICAN
OFFICIALS.
WHO SAID THERE IS SUFFICIENT
REASON FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO NOW
GO INTO MR. COHEN'S OFFICE,
HOTEL ROOM, AND HOME BECAUSE
THEY WORRIED HE WASN'T GOING TO
BE COOPERATIVE AND GIVE THE
EVIDENCE.
>> Jesse: HE HAD BEEN
COOPERATING UP UNTIL THAT POINT.
>> Juan: THE SECOND THING FOR
US HERE AT FOX, THIS IS A BIG
THING ABOUT SEAN HANNITY.
THE QUESTION FOR ME IS, WHY SEAN
DIDN'T DISCLOSE THIS EARLIER
BECAUSE IN THE PREVIOUS TWO
CASES.
SEAN SAYS THERE IS NO THIRD
PARTY, OBVIOUSLY REFERRING TO
THE IDEA THAT COHEN WAS SETTING
UP PAYMENTS TO WOMEN FOR TRUMP
AND ELLIOT BROIDY, THE RNC DONOR
AND ELLIOT BROIDY, THE RNC DONO
DONOR.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
EVIDENCE OF ANYTHING LIKE THAT
WITH SEAN HANNITY.
BUT WHY, WHEN SEAN WAS ON THE
AIR STRONGLY AND ADVOCATE FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, NOT SAY HEY,
I'VE GOT A RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
LAWYER.
I THINK THAT'S A QUESTION.
>> Dana: I THINK PEOPLE KNEW
THAT SEAN AND MICHAEL: HAVE
KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR YEARS.
I HAVE NOT TALKED TO SEAN.
THIS IS MY PERSONAL THEORY.
I THINK IF SEAN WERE TO BE ASKED
TWO DAYS AGO, NAME YOUR LAWYERS,
WOULD HE HAVE SAID MICHAEL: IS
ONE OF HIS LAWYER'S?
PROBABLY NOT.
MICHAEL COHEN SAID HE WAS THE
LAWYER OF SEAN, THE GOAL OF
WHICH I THINK IS TO ASK THE
JUDGE TO PROTECT ANY
CONVERSATIONS HE MIGHT'VE HAD
WITH SEAN.
HE IS SAYING YES, HE'S ADVISED
ME ON THINGS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TOO HAVE PAID A
LAWYER TO HAVE CLIENT ATTORNEY
PRIVILEGE.
I CAN SAY KIMBERLY, YOU CAN
REPRESENT ME TO BE MY LAWYER ON
SOMETHING?
>> Kimberly: FOR A DOLLAR.
>> Dana: FOR A DOLLAR, THEN
EVERYTHING THAT WE TALK ABOUT
CAN BE CLIENT ATTORNEY PRIVILEGE